what we're going to do in this video is
focus on the budget process in the u.s
congress and just as a reminder that's
one of the major functions of the united
states congress is to pass a budget for
the executive branch to decide how much
money the executive branch has to use to
actually function
and when it comes to the budget the two
most powerful committees are the
appropriations committees in the house
of representatives and in the senate
they get to decide how much money goes
to various departments and programs in
the federal government
just for context let's get a broad view
of what the federal budget looks like
and how it has changed over time
so over here you see the trend from the
early 80s all the way until projected a
few years into the future at the time of
this video being created and you can see
the absolute level of the federal budget
has gone from a little under 1 trillion
and it is now approaching 4 trillion
and this view of the breakdown of the
various spending areas gives us a better
sense of some trends as we mentioned in
other videos there's a significant chunk
of mandatory spending mandatory spending
or things that by law we have already
obligated ourselves to
and the big ones here are social
security and medicare and you can see
that they have gone collectively from a
little over 20 percent of the federal
budget to now approaching almost
two-thirds of the federal budget now
another chunk of this budget that we are
obligated to pay is the net interest on
our national debt we are borrowers as a
country and so we need to pay interest
now everything else here you can
consider to be discretionary that would
be this national defense piece right
here in purple and then everything above
this net interest piece and that's what
the appropriations committees are going
to decide on where to spend that money
how much does national defense get and
how much do these other priorities for
the country get
now generally speaking the amount of
money allocated to various programs and
various departments how it is spent
tends to be decided by the executive
branch congress's job is to set the
budget but that is not always the case
congress can also set aside portions of
this budget for specific projects
and the setting aside of parts of the
budget for specific projects
is known as ear marks
and to make things tangible here are
some examples of earmarks from the
highway bill that was passed in 2005.
and as you can see it just lists a bunch
of special projects and this goes on for
tens and sometimes hundreds of pages so
here in california there's a project to
construct safe access to streets for
bicyclists and pedestrians including
crosswalks sidewalks and traffic calming
measures in covina california four
hundred thousand dollars if we go down
here to number five renovate and expand
national packard museum and adjacent
historic packard facilities and that is
almost three million dollars
and so one thing that's probably
crossing your mind is hey this is a
national highway bill and you have these
little projects that seem very very very
local and these earmarks here these
set-asides because they feel sometimes
wasteful or they're being used more as a
political tool versus something that the
federal government should actually worry
about sometimes these types of earmarks
are referred to as pork barrel projects
pork
barrel projects and the reason why i
introduced both words are earmarks are
just a general thing you can decide
whether they're good or bad many of
those earmarks that i listed even though
they are for specific projects in
specific locations they seemed at least
related to the highway bill but it would
be very reasonable for some folks to say
why is congress in the business of
funding these specific projects isn't
their job to just set the budget to
figure out how much the department of
transportation gets and then let them as
part of the executive branch decide how
to execute on improving the national
highway system or our transportation
system and so they would argue that that
is pork that those are pork barrel
projects that those are government waste
now to get a sense of how significant
earmarks and debatably pork barrel have
been in the past
we have this chart from citizens against
government waste and it shows earmarked
spending from 1991 to 2016.
and you will immediately notice some
things going from 1991 all the way until
about 2006 you have this steady upward
trend in earmarked spending all the way
to the peak in 2006 of 29 billion
dollars of ear marks but then something
interesting happens in 2011 it looks
like it gets pretty close to zero and
then it starts trending up from there
but it's much lower than it was before
and that's because as we get into this
period after 2006 earmark spending
become a very big political issue some
of these projects there was famously an
earmark for a bridge to an island in
alaska that was going to cost several
hundreds of millions of dollars it was
later canceled but it got a lot of press
and a lot of politicians started to make
it their mission to do away with earmark
spending some of these pork barrel
projects were easy to get people worked
up about and said hey look this is a
sign of government waste and so in the
end of 2010 both the senate and the
house of representatives passing
resolutions to end earmark spending
although you can see that it still
exists in some way at least according to
the citizens against government waste
now at first this seems very good
because 29 billion dollars on things
like museums or maybe bridges that go to
islands that very few people live on
does not seem like a good idea it seems
like classic examples of government
waste but it's also important to keep it
in context remember the federal budget
is approaching four trillion dollars so
even in 2006 when the federal budget was
a little under three trillion dollars
this was only about one percent of the
federal budget
and so even though earmarks which often
get called pork barrel projects became a
lightning rod for a lot of media
attention because they seemed so
wasteful
in most years they represent well under
one percent of the federal budget and
there are folks who would even argue
that earmarks are a good thing
by essentially allowing congress people
to set aside an earmark for something in
their district it allows it it makes it
easier for bills to get passed and it's
only costing us less than one percent to
do it it's only something that's
streamlining the political process
other arguments they make is these
earmarks aren't spending above and
beyond the regular budget if they do not
set aside this money for these projects
in these various districts or in these
various states well then the executive
branch is just going to decide on how to
use that money and ideally the executive
branch would open these things up for
bid these would be competitive processes
but there's examples of the executive
branch also favoring certain regions or
certain projects so the budget could
arguably be the same whether or not
there are those earmarks it's really a
question of whether it is congress that
is deciding where these special projects
go or whether it is the executive branch
now another term that you might often
hear with the legislative process
something that helps streamline it is
the term log rolling
now log rolling can apply to a lot of
things not just in terms of where you
spend money
log rolling is just the idea that let's
say that i am
congress person a and you are
congressperson b and i really
like this bill right over here i like
bill number one and you like bill number
two and i agree to support you
if you agree to support me here i
described log rolling where we support
each other's bills but we could even
have log rolling where we support each
other's parts of bills for example i'll
support your transportation museum in
your state if you support my bicycle
path in my state
so i'll leave you there the big
takeaways here are to appreciate the
size of the federal budget where it gets
spent and some of the processes used to
help pass that federal budget we also
talked about earmarks which sometimes
get called pork barrel projects and it's
interesting for you to think about after
this video are they good or are they bad
at first especially when you look at the
media attention they seem clearly bad
they seem wasteful but when you think
about that they're less than one percent
of the budget and they might help
streamline the passing of other
important legislation maybe making it
even more bipartisan who knows some
would argue that they might not be as
bad as people first believed you decide